Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I have to pinch myself that I am saying
but, but here goes. Today we are going to
use Google’s amazing new AI to create not an
image, and not even a short image sequence,
but we are going to make an entire film. An
AI-made film, and all this within seconds.
Yes, that’s right. Less than a year ago, in
April 2022, an amazing text to image AI called
DALL-E 2 was published by scientists
at OpenAI. This took a piece of text,
and painted an image for us. It ushered
in a new era of AI-assisted tools.
And then, something amazing happened. And not
6 years later, but about only 6 months later,
in October 2022. This follow up
paper could generate not just images,
but short videos of our choosing,
but even if it did that really well,
this was still made to create only that…short
sequences. A true miracle of AI research.
However, here is another one. And
hold on to your papers, because now,
this new technique called Phenaki promises no
less than entire films made by an AI. Entire
films! Now I am super excited for this, so let’s
have a look at 5 of my favorite examples together.
One. The new work’s superpower is that
we can write several text prompts,
and the AI finds a way to chain them together in
a way that makes sense. That sounds…that sounds
exactly like the script for a movie.
Amazing. If it works, of course. So,
first, we can say “A photorealistic teddy bear
is swimming in the ocean in San Francisco.” Then,
we say “The teddy bear goes underwater.” Then,
“The teddy bear keeps swimming under the water
with colorful fishes.” And finally,
“A panda bear is swimming underwater.”
And the AI finds out by itself how this
magical transformation from teddy bear
to a panda should take place. I love it. Now,
this was really cool, how about another one?
Two. We start out with a side view of an astronaut
who is walking through a puddle on Mars. Who then
starts dancing. I am particularly interested in
these transitionary moments, this one checks out,
really cool. Then, he walks his dog on Mars. And
look at that! The dog does not seem to just grow
out of nothing, but it gradually enters the frame.
Once again, a graceful transition. And then,
the astronaut and this good boy watch
fireworks together. Well, kind of.
Three, I also loved that we can also give
the AI a little more explicit instructions,
for instance, we can ask it to zoom
out at the end of the video when
the campfire appears. And it did
exactly that. Good job, little AI!
Four, the paper also showcases a two and a
half minute long video that starts out with
a scenic motorcycle ride, running through
the woods and finding beautiful things,
of course, robots, and more.
And five, while we look through the beautiful
story of this penguin, let’s talk about pixels.
These are 128x128 videos. That is not a lot
of pixels. Now, of course, these are not super
high-quality videos yet, they do not compare to
the super-high quality images that text to image
AIs are capable of. So why be so excited for this?
Well, we are experienced Fellow Scholars here,
so what do we do? We apply the First Law of
Papers. The First Law Of Papers says that research
is a process. Do not look at where we are, look
at where we will be two more papers down the line.
So, where will we be a couple more papers
down the line? Well, for reference,
this is what DALL-E 1 was capable of,
and just one more paper down the line,
this was possible with DALL-E 2. And looking
at the previous results in image generation,
we are likely having a DALL-E 1 moment for AI
video generation. Yes, this means we are likely
on the cusp of a revolution. Just look at how much
progress can be made in just one paper. Wow. So,
high-quality AI movies are likely not
impossible anymore. And not even decades
away. They might very well be just months
away from now. What a time to be alive!
And, if you wish to be part of this amazing
progress in AI research, consider subscribing
and becoming a Fellow Scholar, and even
better, hitting the bell icon to not miss it.
Now, plus one, this has become one of my favorite
parts of the paper. Get this, it can even animate
an already existing image of ours given a text
prompt. So, we can not only create entire movies,
but we can even tell the AI what kind of
movie we wish to create. Wow. My goodness.
So, what do you think? What would you use
this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!